[Music]
one of the best pieces of advice I got
on this journey was the difference
between a linear life in an exponential
life a linear life is you get an
internship you get a job you get a
promotion you save up for vacation and
you just go step by step slowly and
predictably your whole way through and
again there's nothing wrong with that
but you have to be clear with yourself
about what you want an exponential life
is about deciding that you're not gonna
wait around you're not gonna hope
someone just you know hands you what
you're hoping for and it's about
grabbing on to it for what you want so
over the course of this seven-year
journey whether it was tracking down
Bill Gates which took two years or Lady
Gaga which took three years in every
industry possible Maya Angelou for
poetry Jane Goodall for science
pitbull Quincy Jones Tim Ferriss Larry
King they all couldn't have been more
different on the outside but as I heard
their stories and started to dissect how
they launched their careers I realized
there was this common melody to
everyone's story and the analogy that
came to me because I was 21 at the time
was that it's sort of like getting into
a nightclub so there's always three ways
in there's the first door the main
entrance or the line curves around the
block
where 99% of people wait in line hoping
to get in and then there's the second or
the VIP entrance or the billionaires or
celebrities go through and school has
this way of making us feel like those
the only two ways in your they're born
into it or you wait your turn like
everybody else what I've learned is that
there's always always the third door and
it's the door where you jump out of line
run down the alley bang on the door
hundred times crack over the window go
through the kitchen there's always a way
in and it doesn't matter if that's how
gates all this first piece of software
or how Lady Gaga got her first record
deal they all took the third door so the
third door isn't a prescription or a
recipe it's really a mindset so if you
look at Steven Spielberg the way he did
it was he was rejected from film school
so instead of giving up on his dream he
decided he would take his education into
his own hands
so the way the story goes according to
Spielberg is that one day when he's
around 19 years old he jumped on to a
tour bus at Universal Studios rides
around the lot on this tour jumps off
the bus hides in the bathroom waits for
the bus to drive away and starts walking
around the lot and as he's walking
around he bumps into this man named
Chuck Silver's who works at Universal
Television and Chuck Silver's sees this
kid and says what are you doing here and
Spielberg tells him his dream and they
end up talking for a while and Silver's
goes you wanna come back on the lot
spielberg goes that'd be a dream and
Chuck silvers writes a three-day pass
and Spielberg goes every day back to the
lot for the next three days but on the
fourth day Spielberg puts on a suit gets
his dad's briefcase walks up to the
security entrance puts a hand in the air
and goes hey Scotty and Scotty just
waves back and Spielberg walks right
through and for the next you know months
Spielberg goes back onto the lot going
into editing rooms learning as much as
possible sneaking onto sets and soaking
it all in really creating his own
education he's asking producers out to
lunch talking to actors and actresses
but eventually Chuck Silver's who became
his mentor gave him one of the best
pieces of advice he essentially said
stop schmoozing and go make a quality
short film that you can have in your
hand and show to people and it sort of
bust that myth of it's not you know what
you know it's who you know it's really
also what you know or what you have to
show so Spielberg takes the advice to
heart makes this incredible short film
called Amblin and when Chuck Silver sees
it he's so moved that a single teardrop
falls on his face and Chuck Silver's
reaches for the phone and calls the vice
president of Universal Television Sid
Sheinberg and he go Sid I have something
you have to see and Sid goes look I have
a lot to watch right now is it that
important and Chuck silver goes it's
that goddamn important if you don't
watch this tonight someone else will
Sheinberg watches the film the next day
says he wants to see spielberg
immediately
a seven-year contract on the spot and
that's how he became the youngest
director in Hollywood history the key to
that story though you know of course
Spielberg had incredible talent so did a
lot of other wonderful young directors
the difference between that story and
every other story that doesn't work out
to me is Chuck Silver's who I saw sort
of this inside a man someone inside of
the organization who believed in
Spielberg enough that he put his
reputation on the line if Chuck Silver's
didn't write that three-day pass if he
didn't give him that wonderful advice to
make that short film and if he didn't
call Sid Sheinberg and lay it all out
for him and say it's that goddamn
important none of this would have
happened so anyone who's trying to break
through not really in in an age in life
it's not about an age in life it's about
a stage in life if you're starting
something new if you're reaching for a
dream find that inside man or woman
who's willing to put the reputation on
the line to help you get in so an
exponential life is about very much the
concept of the third door which is
running down the alley banging on the
door finding away in yourself it's about
deciding that life isn't going to slowly
and predictably give you what you want
[Music]